قال لنا المدعي العام السويدي
ماكست انه عثر على اثار مواده متفجره
بالقرب من خطي انابيب نور الشريف واحد
واثنين ما يؤكد تعرض الخطين لعمل تخريبي
وقال المدعي العام السويدي انه خلال
التحقيقات في مسرح الجريمه في بحر البطيخ
اظهرت التحقيقات اثار متفجرات على العديد
من الاجسام الغريبه التي تم العثور عليها
ووصف المدعي العام السويديه التحقيق بانه
معقد للغايه وشامل لافتان الى ان نتائج
التحقيقات المستمره ستؤكد امكانيه تقديم
اي شخص لاي اشتباه في ارتكابه جريمه وكان
تفجيرا قد الحق اضرارا بخطين واحد واثنين
في بحر البطيخ وتبادلت روسيا والدول
الغربيه الاتهامات بشان المسؤوليه عن
التفجير في حينه
قناه المتحدث باسم الرئاسه الروسيه
ديميتري بسكو فينا بلاده ترحب بتاكيد
السويد فرضيه الهجوم الارهابيه على خطوط
انابيب غاز نورسين واضاف بيسكوف ان هذا
يؤكد مره اخرى المعلومات التي تملكها
روسيا مشددا على ضروره تحديد الجهه التي
تقف وراء هذا الانفجار